- Hey, guys,
my name's Rick Rabjohn.
Welcome to
the Booyah Forge.
This is the power hammer
that I made
about three years ago;
it works great.
A little bit
of the wall of fame.
Just different knives
I've made.
This is my tabar battle axe.
A Viking axe.
This is my King Kong
forge press.
It's a 20-ton forge press,
and I use that a lot.
That works really great.
This is a beautiful Hill anvil
back from the 1850s.
I've got my coal forge
I built.
[chuckles] It's an upside-down
trash can.
And this is the propane forge
I built.
It works really well.
All right, that's it
for the forge area.
Let's go over to the shop
and see--
see that portion of it.
- Hello. This is my forge.
Come on in.
Got my quench tank here...
which I built out
of an oxygen bottle.
I cut the bottom off
and flipped it upside down
so I can drain the oil out.
This is my forge.
I incorporated my forge
into my work bench
because some pieces I do
I need to go straight
from the fire to a jig
that I have laid
out on a table.
If you look at the setup,
you have 6 feet from
the center of the fire pot
to the striking surface.
So there's very
little heat loss.
That's paramount
when you're working.
Like little work triangles--
they just--it speeds up
your efficiency.
- All right, guys,
welcome to the shop.
Here's my 2x72-inch
belt grinder.
I made that--
the milling machine,
cutting and welding.
You know, my drill press.
All the different grinders.
And then of course my band saw.
I don't specialize
in any one thing.
There's a couple of examples.
I've got a beautiful kinetic
wind sculpture
in the back. And then
of course I've got
some decorative iron work
here.
It's time for me
to go back to work.
All right, take care, guys.
- This was gonna be
a coffee table.
The wife and I--Patti and I got
back from a trip to Scotland,
but I wound up going
to a lot of castles
while I was over there,
down on my hands and knees on
the floor looking at hinges
and stuff the ancient smiths
did.
And this kind of inspired me
a little bit.
This was gonna go through...
But Patti said, "No. I'll be
catching my pantyhose on it
left and right,"
and that was the end of that.
I hung onto them.
I'm not gonna get rid of them.
They're nice. I like them.
So I'll use them for something
eventually, I guess.